avec nos charles vaillancourt président
de l'association des producteurs
d'arbres de noël du québec bonsoir
monsieur vaillancourt
bonjour est ce qu'il ya une pénurie nous
parce qu'on a envie encore plus aux
états unis
écoutez on veut pas dire le mot pénurie
c'est sûr qu'on sait qu'il ya une énorme
demande cette année puis les producteurs
ont beaucoup moins d'arbres coupés donc
c'est sûr qu'ils vue devra avoir un
manque le au courant de cette année il
le met encore une fois ça va être
dépendamment de la demande des
consommateurs mais mais pourquoi il ya
moins et d'arbres cette année c'est
vraiment le gel et la sécheresse qui ont
tué des arbouts pourquoi il ya moins
d'arbres
oui mais par contre si le faux faut
prendre en compte que l'arbre de noël
ça prend environ dix à douze ans avant
d'atteindre sa pleine maturité qui va
jouer alentours de 6 à 7 pieds donc
excusez moi donc
dans les années 2008 et 2010 il y avait
beaucoup trop d'arbres sur le marché
pendant la crise économique beaucoup
moins les prix et à la baisse donc les
producteurs ont soif est fake vendu leur
entreprise ou juste laissé leurs tables
aller parce que veut pas le coût de
produits de la profitabilité n'était
juste plus lol donc là c'est pour ça que
le creux de vague s'est fait ressentir
ce que l'auteur a donc huit ans on alla
- planté oui c'est exact depuis lors je
vais pas faire pousser un arbre plus
vite évidemment ça prend les gras les
beaux affaires de là on va essayer c'est
cher ce après quoi les plus graves pas
combien d'années plus tôt depuis l'iran
tout dépendamment un arbre qui vont être
9 10 pieds on peut parler jusqu'à 14
acquises à mme donc c'est très long nous
les producteurs on va acheter un à
donald va déjà avoir 50 c'est un plan
qui va probablement être un pied et demi
donc pour le rendre ensuite jusqu'à 6 et
7 pieds ça va prendre jusqu'à huit ans
donc on parle peu et maddin 12 ans leur
a regardé knows how to c'est donc c'est
pas évident puis comme vous dites le
avec les réchauffements que les
réchauffement climatique les jeunes
brittany les sécheresses ça nous
complique encore plus la ville pour
produire les abdos est ce un vrai que
vous en vendez davantage aux etats unis
aussi
c'est sûr qu'il ya une forte demande aux
états unis aussi le monde ne se fait pas
juste se ressentir au québec ou au
canada il se fait ressentir le au marché
global puis les états unis ont vécu la
même chose en 2008 et en 2010 et oui de
très gros acheteurs nord sont venus à
faire le tour de plusieurs producteurs
pour pouvoir acheter des abonnés du
québec est-ce que interminable savall en
cours ça reste une bonne affaire parce
que c'est quand même on le disait le les
prix ont monté beaucoup
pour un producteur cccp 1
c'est payant mais encore une fois on
veut pas traîner notre client on veut
pas tenu une clientèle on veut pas faire
mal nous c'est à nos parts de marché
contre guarani parce que je veux pas on
a toujours eu la guerre la bague
horizons en classe de neige artificielle
et l'abdomen naturel puis je pense qu'il
faut pour que la réelle nature elle perd
des plumes à cause de pirelli oui ça va
se rétablir rétablir le courant des
prochaines années mais comme je vous dis
c'est pas c'est quoi le but premier non
plus de d'augmenter pas des grosses
augmentations je pense que
l'augmentation de 5 à 10 % vont se faire
ressentir cette année mais on veut pas
on veut pas montée
exponentielle mais n'ont pu en tout cas
on voit que la tradition des armes
naturelles se poursuit play quelque
chose d'encourageant là dedans je voyais
encore merci nous avons parlé mais merci
à vous bonne fée joueurs